Überfall auf die Ukraine bringt es an
den Tag
Querfront lautet der Verdacht und die
hat schon eine gewisse Tradition
die linke und die AFD kann man sie in
einen Topf werfen jetzt in der Phönix
Runde
herzlich Willkommen bei uns meine Gäste
im Studio ist Julia reschenbach
Politikwissenschaftlerin der Freien
Universität Berlin
Ann-Kathrin Müller
afd-expertin im hauptstadtbüro
von Politik Magazin Cicero und Professor
Werner Patzelt früher Lehrstuhlinhaber
an der Technischen Universität in
Dresden und jetzt wissenschaftlicher
Direktor in Brüssel für die ungarische
oder regierungseinheit Denkfabrik
Matthias Kollegium willkommen bei uns
Frau Müller sie waren am Samstag ja auf
der Demo in Berlin Knecht alles
schwarzer und andere um
gegen Waffenlieferungen und für
Friedensverhandlungen zu demonstrieren
wen haben sie da eigentlich angetroffen
auf der Demonstration lagen sich da
wirklich links und rechts in den Armen
also da wurde jetzt nicht geschunkelt
aber tatsächlich ist es so dass ich da
das Milieu angetroffen habe was ich seit
knapp drei Jahren auf den
corona-maßnahmen Demos finde aus dem
Querdenker Milieu afdler rechtsextreme
Neonazis die waren alle da und natürlich
waren da dann eben weil Wagenknecht und
schwarze aufgerufen haben auch alt linke
und Altkommunisten aber es war schon
sehr sehr deutlich dass alle vereint hat
sozusagen das Pro russische auf eine Art
und Weise und dann eben dazu die Sorge
wie sie sagen vor einem möglichen
weiteren Eskalation des Krieges ohne
aber ja erklären zu können was das jetzt
bringen soll einfach so gut zu sagen
werden Frieden
riesigen war das ein Tabubruch was wir
auf dieser Demonstration gesehen haben
nein von der Tabubruch kann man nicht
sprechen wir müssen ja sehen dass es
einfach eine diskursverengung in
Deutschland gibt und das zieht dann
Leute an aus unterschiedlichen Milieus
aus unterschiedlichen Lagern wenn
sozusagen so eine Alternative angeboten
wird mal gegen gegen den Mainstream zu
demonstrieren und das ist ähm höchst
bedenklich und aber ein Tabubruch ist es
nicht das hat die Kollegin ja schon
gesagt es gab ähnliches auch schon bei
anderen Themen wo viele Menschen
offenbar auch so eine diskursverengung
vermuten wahrnehmen fühlen ja es ist
ganz kurz ich habe nicht gesagt dass das
kein Tabu buchbar ist weil das schon neu
ist ist das
geil der bürgerliche Konsens man geht
nicht mit rechtsextreme zusammen auf die
Straße und es gibt Leute die sagen ich
bin bürgerlich und ich bin links und ich
bin jetzt trotzdem hingegangen und ich
finde es nicht bürgerlich wenn man mit
den Leuten die ich da eben beschrieben
habe auf die Straße geht dass sie von
einer trotz Haltung auch gesprochen
haben weil man
nicht erst seit 19 wird Sarah
Wagenknecht von ganz rechts
bejubelt bzw jetzt auch umworben was
macht sie dort zu interessant
ja die ist glaube ich eine
Identifikationsfigur für viele gerade im
Osten auch aus eigener biografischer
Begründung heraus ein zweifelt ohne auch
rhetorisches Talent dass sie hat
Positionen sehr medienwirksam und auch
sehr prägnant zu formulieren und sie ist
eben ein potenziell geeignetes Phänomen
aus Sicht der AFD und der neuen Rechten
eine ich nenne es mal tatsächlich
Führungsfigur zu gewinnen die womöglich
charismatisch auch eine gewisse
Anschlussfähigkeit noch mal in neue
Schichten und Wählergruppen ermöglichen
könnte
stimmen der Eindruck dass diese Allianz
besonders in Ostdeutschland auf
fruchtbaren Boden fällt der Eindruck
stimmt sehr wohl die AFD hat ihre
Hochburgen im Osten und hat den Protest
ostdeutsche Bevölkerung gegen die früher
hieß das übergestimmte westdeutsche
System von der
immer zum Ausdruck gebracht und die
Linkspartei die lange Zeit die
hauptsächliche Sachwalterin dieses Amtes
Protestes im Osten gewesen ist sie ist
im Vergleich zu AFD zurückgefallen weil
auch die sozusagen Schichten die jeweils
vertreten werden und die Positionierung
gerade bei der Migrationspolitik der AFD
Leute zu und der Linkspartei Leute
weggetrieben haben das heißt diese
Wählerwanderung die wir bei den letzten
Landtagswahlen oder auch bei den
Bundestagswahlen in Ostdeutschland
gesehen haben direkt von der Linkspartei
zur AFD gibt sich genau aus dieser
dieser Wahrnehmung dass da ein anderer
besserer neuer Sachwalter aus Sicht der
Wählerinnen und Wähler entsteht
entstanden ist das gute Gefühl der
Linkspartei nach der Wiedervereinigung
eben sehr stark artikuliert war dass es
mit dieser Wiedervereinigung so nichts
wird das falsche Weichenstellung gemacht
werden und das Grundgefühl bei der AFD
ist seitdem ist sie eben gibt 2013 mit
eurer Rettungspolitik begonnen das
Grundgefühl deren Anhänger ist genau das
gleiche es geht einfach die Politik in
die falsche Richtung die Anfangspunkte
beide sind verschieden aber die
Zielpunkte systemprotest es funktioniert
nicht zurecht wir wollen nicht diese
Politik die verbindet beide jetzt
gibt es ja Ähnlichkeiten auch zwischen
diesen beiden Parteien schon seit
längerer Zeit zu beobachten also
Berührungspunkte habe ich sie am Anfang
genannt ich nenne mal ein paar
Stichworte die Flüchtlingspolitik seit
2015 die Skepsis gegen die
corona-maßnahmen Stichwort Corona
Diktatur das verachten dieser Wolken
oder Bahnen Eliten eine propotin eine an
die amerikanische Haltung auch
antisemitische Tendenzen Boykott gegen
Israel dieser Alkohol Marsch in Berlin
Klimapolitik das sind alles
Themenbereiche wo sich links und ganz
links und ganz rechts zum Teil getroffen
haben woran liegt das genau also dass
das jetzt bei der Flüchtlingspolitik und
also bei zahlreich
gesagt hat man muss schon einmal sagen
es gibt einen kleinen Teil bei der
Linken der sich in manchen Punkten sehr
ähnlich rhetorisch verhält wie die AFD
das ist eben Russland das ist teilweise
die Migrationspolitik
ist teilweise der Antisemitismus und
dann hört es aber auch schon auf dann
haben wir eine AFD die durch und durch
so ist also deswegen ich würde die
sendungsfrage mit meinen beantworten
weil wir eben ein sehr kleinen Teil der
Linken haben die in bestimmten Themen so
ist aber nicht in der Gänze wie die AFD
ebenso ablehnend gegenüber dem System
und den Spielen
da wird ja auch vom Wagenknecht Flügel
mal vorgeworfen die würden sozusagen
weit weg von der Realität leben die
Basis der Linken würde da ganz anders
denken nee das ist klarer Populismus von
Sarah Wagenknecht das ist eben das was
meint dass sie eben sehr geschickt
spricht zu behaupten dass eben nur sie
für alle spreche dass sie wüsste was das
Beste wäre für die deutschen ist ähnlich
wie die AFD überhaupt nur sie könne
dieses Land noch retten als wäre dieses
Land kurz Abgrund was man ja absehen
kann dass das nicht stimmt
das noch mal die Frage zwischen Teilen
der AFD ich nenne es jetzt mal warten
mit Flügel selbst wenn das jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen unscharf ist und
der also zwischen Teilen der Linken also
der bankknecht Flügel und der AFD dass
man in diesen Themenbereichen die ich
jetzt gerade da zitiert habe doch häufig
ganz ähnlich Überzeugungen hat fast
gleich Überzeugung ja ich finde man darf
wortgleiche Überzeugungen nicht gemein
machen mit sozusagen hat man den
dieselbe Zielrichtung die Begründung ist
ja häufig eine gänzlich andere wenn man
mal auf ein Beispiel schaut zum Beispiel
Freihandelsabkommen das wäre so ein
Thema im wo die einen also die Linken
sagen das wollen wir ab weil wir große
Konzerne nicht noch reicher machen
wollen das ist also eine ganz andere
Argumentationslogik als wenn man AFD
seit ich zum Beispiel sagt wir leben das
ab weil wir im Grunde national uns gegen
Globalisierung gegen
supernationale und internationale
Zusammenarbeit stellen also man kommt
zwar am Ende tatsächlich in bestimmten
Punkten dann zur gemeinsamen Position
also man lernt zum Beispiel eine Sache
ab auf beiden Seiten aber die Begründung
ist eine ganz ich glaube da muss man
wirklich genau hinschauen weil das eben
auch der Moment ist wo man diese Lager
dann sieht wo man eben nicht den Fehler
oder es sich so einfach machen darf zu
sagen Sarah Wagenknecht ist die Linke
das würde ich sofort sagen ist nämlich
gerade nicht der Fall man müsste über
ihre Rolle in dieser Partei glaube ich
noch mal differenzierter sprechen um an
den Punkt zu kommen zu fragen ist man
wirklich in Gänze deckungsgleich da bin
ich bei Frau Müller und das sehe ich
nicht so wir sind immer noch in der
Abteilung Definition und Begriffsklärung
gibt es ist der Nationalismus der Linken
fremd in Deutschland dann nationalismus
ist der linke nicht vollständig fremd
die Linke für das aber eher als
patriotisch eben sende der deutschen
Sozialdemokratie war der Bewilligung der
kriegsredite von 1914 auffassen man wird
eher die Sache so wahrnehmen müssen die
Ähnlichkeiten von beiden AFD und
Linkspartei kommen und davon wird dass
beide populistische Bewegungen sind die
Linkspartei ist eher eine
sozialpopulistische Bewegung die AF eher
den nationalpopulistische Bewegung des
nationale und das soziale berühren
einander ab und zu weil der
Migrationspolitik ist es Frau
Wagenknecht gewesen die sozusagen die
Verteilungskonflikte schon frühzeitig
angesprochen hat bei der
Auseinandersetzung mit dem Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine ist
Populismus einer der sozusagen
gefühlsmäßig Nähe zu Russland bei den
Rechten kommen sie davon her dass
eigentlich immer die deutsche Rechte und
die russische Aristokratie der russische
terroristische Staat gute Beziehungen
miteinander hatten und bei der Linken
kommen sie aus der Zeit ist aus
westkonfliktes als Russland also dieser
Werte Union der Hort der Vernunft des
Guten ist richtigen und der US-Amerika
ist USA amerikanische Imperialismus das
Übel war so wird man sich Ähnlichkeiten
zusammen reimen können also riesigen
jetzt haben wir schon gelernt also es
gibt unterschiedliche Ursachen man
trifft sich in dem ein oder anderen
politischen inhaltlichen Bereich mit
ähnlichen Überzeugungen es gibt ja so
Begriffe die sich bei uns in Jahrzehnten
eingeschlagen
progressive linke und
nationalkonservative Rechte
auf der anderen Seite wie passt das
jetzt zusammen eigentlich was ein die da
ich würde zunächst noch mal wieder
sprechen ich glaube die mit den die
Linke da zu retten indem man sagt dass
sie bei
Frauen selbstabkommen irgendwie eine
andere Position hat deswegen geht ja
keiner zu Demo die die Linkspartei
sammelt im Moment Leute ein genau wie
die AFD die mit mit allgemeinem Diskurs
nicht zufrieden sind und da hier die
Linkspartei jetzt noch mal so
auszudifferenzieren da bin ich mal
gespannt die nächsten Tage ich mal die
Linkspartei ist ja kurz vom Ende und
jetzt könnte es sein dass sie dich
deswegen ähm bei Wahlen sind sie am Ende
und jetzt könnte es sein dass sie den
Strohhalm warenknecht ergreifen also
wenn ich die aktuellen Meldung heute
sehe ist für Donnerstag im ein ähm hat
die Fraktion sich darauf geeinigt sich
auf Frankreich Linie zu commitmenten und
wenn die Linkspartei jetzt um sich zu
retten den Wagenknecht Kurs geht dann
ist dann ist doch ganz klar dass mit den
Kandidat zu machen ist ich frage mich
dann auch ob man in Berlin noch mit
denen koalieren kann wenn sie jetzt auf
dem Wagenknecht Kurs
eingehen und natürlich hat die Linke
auch sowas nationalsoziales ja also ich
meine wir wollen uns um uns kümmern und
uns interessiert
die Organe nicht dass das hat was
nationales aber ich verstehe jetzt nicht
so ganz die Linke hat sich ja total
wegbewegt von Wagenknecht und wenn man
ehrlich ist war der Samstag ein totaler
Flop 13.000 Leute sagt die Polizei
selbst wenn man da zwei 3000 mehr
zunimmt das ist doch ein Flop das ist
doch keine neue Friedensbewegung das ist
keine neue Wagen nicht Bewegung das ist
nicht meine neue Partei wenn da jetzt
irgendwie 50.000 LeuTe gestanden hätten
wie die behaupten hätte sie da ja
vielleicht verkündet dass sie etwas neu
startet also sie sammelt wieder Leute
ein noch fährt sie mit diesem Kurs
bewegt sich die Linke auf sie zu
zumindest sagt mein Kollege der sich da
sehr gut auskennt das nicht ähm und ich
wage wäre mich auch dagegen jetzt hier
dieses Hufeisen Theorie die ist aus
guten Gründen umstritten weil man eben
das eine mit dem anderen nicht
vergleichen kann selbst den krassen
Linksextremismus kann man nicht eins zu
eins mit dem Rechtsextremismus
vergleichen wenn man sich zum Beispiel
fand ich nicht vergleichen
vieles aber gleichsetzen kann man sie
nicht weil wenn man sich überlegt dass
man irgendwie wenn man aus dem
Rechtsextremismus aussteigen will man
irgendwie Schutz braucht und eine
aussteigehilfe bei den Linken geht man
einfach nicht mehr zu treffen hin dann
sieht man dass das zwei unterschiedliche
Dinge sind und auch das eine geht sehr
stark gegen Menschengruppen ist sehr
rassistisch getrieben und so weiter da
ist auch der Unterschied bei AFD und
Linke die AFD ist durch und durch
rassistisch die AFD ist durch und durch
gegen dieses System wie es gerade
stattfindet sie will alles abschaffen so
wie es gerade ist sie macht alle anderen
Parteien nieder es macht die Linke in
der Form nicht und ja ich will den Link
überhaupt nicht so viel verteidigen da
gibt es
irre und ihre Leute da gibt es Leute die
Putin bis sonst so in verteidigen das
ist alles nicht diskutabel aber man kann
sie absolut nicht gleichsetzen es gibt
einen Unterschied ich jetzt mal die das
etwas moderate Geschwisterchen das
Extremismus nämlich den Populismus es
gibt ein Unterschied zwischen links
Populismus und rechts Populismus
Populismus ist nicht eine Grundhaltung
auf bestimmte Emotionen auf bestimmte
Nerven zu ziehen sondern das ist schon
eine ideologisch auch differenzierte Art
naja natürlich inhaltlich schon aber
Populisten eint ja und populistin dass
sie auf große komplexe Fragen einfacher
Antworten anbieten und Frau Müller hat
anfangs deutlich gemacht das ist im
Grunde das was wir natürlich bei Sarah
Wagenknecht sehen wenn Sie zum Beispiel
jetzt pauschal sagt wir schlagen Putin
Frieden vor und keine Antwort auf die
Frage hat wie soll das aussehen also man
macht es sich schlichtweg einfach und da
einen sich Populisten von links und
rechts miteinander ich möchte auch noch
mal darauf wirklich insistieren Sarah
Wagenknecht ist nicht die Linke auch ich
will mich hier bei weitem nicht zur
Verteidigerin der Linkspartei auf
schwingen aber ich glaube die
Differenzierung ist deshalb wichtig weil
natürlich sehen wir eine Partei die
derzeit einen Spagat vollführt wir sehen
einen Bundesvorstand der sich abgrenzt
der sich massiv ausgesprochen hat gegen
diese Demonstration wir sehen eine
Fraktion die Uneinigkeit zeigt die
offensichtlich noch um eine Reaktion um
ein gemeinsames Stimmungsbild bringt wir
sehen innerhalb Berlins sie haben es
angesprochen eben natürlich auch
Bezirksverbände die sich etwa für diese
Kundgebung stark gemacht haben also man
kann jetzt auch nicht sagen da ist alles
salopp formuliert Friede Freude
Eierkuchen aber ich würde trotzdem auch
angesichts dessen ich muss es nicht
wiederholen was frau Müller gesagt hat
davor warnen daraus pauschal eine
Gleichsetzung der beiden Parteien zu
versuchen insbesondere noch mal Angriff
dann das was Sie gesagt haben Herr
Patrick bei der AFD ist es eben nicht
mehr so dass wir von einer Protestpartei
sprechen können die aus Unmut oder aus
abgehängt dich sein gewählt wird sondern
sie hat inzwischen eine gefestigte
stammen die also einstellungsbezogen
diese Partei wählt und bei diesen
einstellungsbezogenen Fragen stechen
zwei Dinge ganz massiv heraus das ist
migrationskritische feindliche
Positionierung einerseits und
andererseits Demokratie skeptische in
der Regel auch eher Demokratie
feindliche Position
wenn wir jetzt herausfinden dass
C und Linke nicht dasselbe sind können
wir uns dazu gratulieren herausgefunden
und zu haben dass ein Kreis keine Ecken
hat das ist das so selbstverständlich
wie gerade etwas das AFD und Linkspartei
nicht dasselbe sind die Fragestellung
lautet worin ähnelt sich im Moment ihr
Auftreten und ihre Anziehungskraft und
dann müssen wir für ein wenig Begriff
sie gehen sagen das erste ist vorhin
schon benannt worden vergleichen und
gleichsetzen ist nicht dasselbe und wer
vergleichen und gleichsetzen gleichsetze
bei dem wir sozusagen intellektuell
Hopfen normal verloren ob etwas gleich
oder verschiedenes bekommen nur raus
nachdem man es verglichen hat und wir
haben eine lange genug Linksparteien AFD
verglichen und wissen dass sie nicht
dasselbe sind das andere ist Begriff
hygienisch anzufügen zu ihrem Wort paar
von Populismus und Extremismus es führt
nicht zu wirklichen Erkenntnisquellen
wenn man Populismus oder Extremismus
inhaltlich definieren will es sind
normale Begriffe Populismus meint
Vereinfachung und zwar nicht in die
taktische sondern in demagogische
Absicht Populismus meint die da oben
machen etwas was wir da unten nicht
wollen folglich müssen wir uns gegen die
da oben wehren warum müssen wir das tun
weil wir das Volk im wissen was richtig
ist und die da oben nicht das ist der
Kern die kernträger sozusagen vom
Populismus und für Extremismus müssen
wir auch nicht viel Neues erfinden was
Extremismus ist das
Bundesverfassungsgericht beim Verbot der
sozialistischen Reichspartei Nachfolger
Organisation der NSDAP 1952 ausgeführt
es ist der Kampf gegen die freiheitlich
demokratische Grundordnung die vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht sehr präzise
definiert worden ist und der ganzen
Tätigkeit unsere Sicherheitsorgane
zugrunde liegt beides ist nicht
inhaltlich gefüllt also
unterschiedlichsten Motiven aus
unterschiedlichsten Herkünften kann man
so albern sein so etwas Wertvolles wie
die freiheitlich demokratische
Grundordnung zu bekämpfen und wenn nicht
die freiheitliche demokratische
Grundordnung bekämpft aber es an
differenziert hat dann Wissen an guten
Willen beim Diskutieren fehlen lässt ja
der macht dann eben sich schuldig der
populistischen Trias Vereinfachung der
Demokratie Willen wir haben Recht und
die da oben müssen Weg auf die Partei
DIE LINKE kommen sie haben gesagt die
Fraktion die Bundestagsfraktion würde
ich jetzt quasi auf die wagenlichtlinie
einschwenken das ist ja insofern
erstaunlich als ja bisher die bisherige
parteienfraktionsführung sich mit Sahra
Wagenknecht seit Jahren streitet die hat
sich regelrecht zerlegt möglicherweise
auch ein Grund für das schlechte
Abschneiden z.B bei der Bundestagswahl
hat immer so das Gefühl gehabt dass man
zumindestens dass die Linke
Parteiführung dann noch so eine Art
Beißhemmung hat gegenüber Sarah
magenknecht weil sie natürlich mit ihrer
Popularität auch ihre Partei hilft das
heißt jetzt aus ihrer Sicht ähm
riesig würde das würde dieser Gegensatz
wieder verschwinden und die Partei rückt
wieder ein Stück Richtung Wagenknecht
es wäre einen Strohhalm an den sie sich
klammern könnten ich meine die Partei
ist in einer schweren Krise sie hat bei
der Bundestagswahl 4,9 Prozent langsam
normalerweise wäre sie nicht im
Bundestag vertreten durch eine
Nettigkeit im Wahlrecht kann sie mit
voller funktionsstärke einziehen obwohl
sie nur drei Direktmandate gewonnen hat
sie hat direkt man hatte auch verloren
hatte diese saß da sie hat massiven
Streit im Vorstand Frau Wissler hat da
trotz künstliche Vergangenheit also so
ganz so harmlos ist es alles nicht und
nun versuchen sie sich zur
Bundestagswahl irgendwie aufzustellen
und da verstehe ich schon das Strategen
sagen vielleicht müssen wir doch so eine
beliebte Frauen und seinen Reihen
irgendwie wieder mitnehmen also es ist
könnte im schlimmsten Fall könnte man
eine Analogie ziehen zu migrationskrise
die AFD ähm
die Wiederauferstehung ermöglicht hat
Gott sei es geklagt und wenn die linke
jetzt mit voller Macht die Partei wird
die diese sozusagen diese
friedensverhandlungsschimäre sinkt
könnte ich mir vorstellen dass sie das
wird Dir das hilft gern noch bei der
Person Sahra Wagenknecht bleiben das ist
fällt ja auf Sie als schillernde Figur
rhetorisch beschlagen auch mit sie hat
auch viele viele Gegner viele Kritiker
viele die sie hassen aber eben auch
viele unterstützarbeit über die Partei
hinaus auf der anderen Seite eine
ziemlich
farblose Partei und Fraktionsführung die
schlingert auch untereinander die
offensichtlich ja kein Kompass hat
im Gegensatz scheinbar im Gegensatz zu
Sarah Wagenknecht die weiß was sie will
liegt da ein großes Problem in der
Partei ich glaube grundsätzlich muss man
sagen das Fraktion und Partei da so ein
bisschen auseinander gehen in der
Fraktion sind halt viele Wagenknecht
Leute noch deswegen auch da der versucht
da irgendwie noch was zu retten sie
selbst hat ja gestern Abend so
angedeutet so noch meine Partei also wer
weiß wie lange das Spiel noch dauert
natürlich hat sie aber die Wirkung weil
sie ja noch drin ist und eben dieses
Spannungsfeld quasi erzeugt ich finde es
interessant dass sie sagen rhetorisch
geschlagen grundsätzlich natürlich aber
ich finde die letzten Monate haben
gezeigt
ehrlicherweise nicht also wenn man seit
Monaten nicht erklären kann wie ist denn
gehen soll obwohl es also sie sagt immer
es gibt keine Friedensverhandlungen
es funktioniert für eben diesen kleinen
Teil wie gesagt ich finde es ist ein
Flop wenn er nur diese Leute da stehen
die ihr seit vielen Jahren irgendwie auf
die Straße gehen man sieht auch 2014 gab
es ja auch schon mal ähnliche Proteste
die haben sich jetzt ein bisschen
erweitert was die Gruppen angeht aber
wenn man sich überlegt sie sagt immer es
gibt keine friedensverhandlung Olaf
Scholz telefoniert immer noch regelmäßig
mit Herrn Putin bei also es gibt ja
Kontakt es gibt versuche diese Krise zu
lösen so da kommt nichts also finde da
haben auch die Medien bisschen eine
Verantwortung dass man sie eben immer
wieder immer wieder dasselbe sagen lässt
und man eben nicht den Schritt weiter
kommt was heißt das denn jetzt
eigentlich ähm aber natürlich hat sie
offenkundig eine Wirkmacht und die
begrenzt sich aber offensichtlich dann
doch offen relativ überschaubare Zahl
die Frage ist ja nutzt
äh Sahra Wagenknecht und ihr Ehemann
Oskar Lafont den nutzen die der linken
oder schaden sie ihr ihr
findet das ganz spannend dieses Bild
dass wir jetzt hier gerade entwickeln
wer hat jetzt eben von der
Anziehungskraft der Linken gesprochen
und das finde ich es erstaunlich weil
die Partei leitet ja gerade darunter
dass sie gegenwärtig offensichtlich
nicht hinreichend anziehen ist wenn man
auf die letzten Wahlergebnisse
zurückschaut Berlin vielleicht als
kleine Ausnahme wo man sich halbwegs
stabil hat halten können es scheint also
eher die Frage dann um die
Anziehungskraft von Sarah Wagenknecht zu
gehen und noch mal das ist ja nicht die
Linke ich bin mir nicht sicher
der zwiespalt-partei Fraktion wurde ja
beschrieben ob man wirklich dauerhaft
davon im nutzen sprechen kann mein
Eindruck ist eher wir wissen aus der
Wahlforschung Parteien die mehrheitlich
mit sich selbst beschäftigt sind werden
nicht gewählt Parteien die also
innerlich zerstritten sind die im Grunde
gar keine Gelegenheit haben ein
programmatisches Profil zu entwickeln
weil sie mehr inneren Personal Debatten
sich verhaken und das ist ja schon ein
Außenbild dass man in den letzten
Monaten man kann fast sagen fast im
letzten Jahr gezeigt hat gerade in der
Debatte um Sarah gedankenknecht die ja
immer wieder wochenweise hochkocht
insofern könnte man auch mal in den Raum
stellen und da ist eben auch dieses
Spannungsfeld parteifraktion jetzt zu
beobachten in den nächsten Tagen und
Wochen ob es nicht sogar einen klärenden
Charakter haben könnte wenn man jetzt
doch an den Punkt kommt zu sagen und die
Frage ist kommt man dahin das ist nicht
die Position dieser Partei das ist nicht
die Linke sondern wenn Sie das
programmatisch anbieten will einen links
populistisch links in Teilen vielleicht
sogar ins extremistisch abgedriftende
Parteiprogramm dann muss sie was Eigenes
machen aber dann distanzieren wir uns
jetzt auch klarer davon um ein eigenes
Angebot zu machen ich weiß nicht ob die
strategische Idee wir nutzen das als
Strohhalm tatsächlich dauerhaft
verfangen würde und auch anschließend an
das was frau Müller gesagt hat 13.000
und wenn man jetzt mal abzieht all jene
die man so hatte eigentlich der
zumindest auch selbst zu Beginn der
Demonstration gesagt die man da gar
nicht haben wollte dann bleiben ja noch
viel viel weniger Leute übrig die
überhaupt gekommen sind bei jedem
Bundesligaspiel sitzen dreimal so viel
Menschen als ich glaube auch da muss man
ein bisschen gucken dass man Marcel bei
der Frage wie erfolgreich war jetzt
wirklich dieses Wochenende nicht für die
Linke sondern für Sarah Bank nicht
die Frage wird Sarah Wagenknecht
dämonisiert oder wird sie banalisiert
nun eine so kluge Frau wie Frau
Wagenknecht kann man schlecht
banalisieren obwohl manches an ihrer
friedensrhetorik denn das den Bereich
des Banalen durchaus inzwischen mehr als
nur streift nein nein dämonisiert ist
auch nicht richtig sie ist einfach die
Paradiesvogel in der Linken sie ist eine
intellektuell wie persönlich attraktive
Frau welche in Diskussionen jede Menge
von anderen Linksparteien Menschen ganz
locker irgendwohin steckt was die
Anziehungskraft der Linken betrifft
sollte man sie auch nicht vollständig
abschreiben auch wenn sie nur not in den
letzten Bundestag gekommen sind ich
verweise auf Bodo ramello in Thüringen
eine Linkspartei die eine bodenständige
vernünftige Politik ohne Übertreibungen
macht ja die wird sogar als mindest
Kabinett von der CDU toleriert auch weil
es dann nicht anders geht das wichtigste
aber schalten mir zu sein dass die Linke
nur deswegen derzeit aus der
verbreiteten Frieden sehen sucht nicht
mehr nicht saugen kann weil eben dafür
im Moment die falschen regieren stellen
Sie sich nur vor nach der letzten
Bundestagswahl wäre CDU Grüne und FDP an
die Macht gekommen und würde die gleiche
Politik machen die Bundeskanzler Scholz
jetzt betreibt wir hätten sehr vereinte
linke Demonstrationen auf den Straßen es
ist nur das eigene politische Lager das
wohl gemerkt mit vernünftigen Gründern
mit vernünftigen Gründern eine Politik
macht die vielen linken emotional gegen
den Strich geht Frieden schaffen ohne
Waffen war immer schon eine linke
Hoffnung und auch da waren nicht viel
dazu gesagt worden wie man den Frieden
ohne Waffen schaffen kann insbesondere
dann wenn das eigene Land überfallen
wird wie Polen von Nazi Deutschland dass
die Linke mit ihrer Friedenssehnsucht
häufig Sprechblasen absondert die
emotional begeistern sind aber
intellektuell wenig zu Problemen Lösung
beitragen das ist nichts Neues und das
würde ich der Linken im Moment auch
nicht vorwerfen dass ihr außer dem
Verlangen nach Verhandlungen nicht
einfällt worüber denn wäre
hat ja oft über den Spagat gesprochen
den Sahra Wagenknecht dahin legt
hinlegen muss wahrscheinlich auch sie
hat ja immer wieder mal kokettiert mit
der Gründung einer eigenen Partei muss
vor einer solchen Partei Gründung
eigentlich die AFD in Ostdeutschland
viel mehr Angst haben als die Linke die
der dann eine aus dem Fleisch vom
Fleisch der Linken eine neue Konkurrenz
Erwachen erwachsen würde ja das ist
spannend zu sehen vielleicht haben wir
noch mal eben auf das Potential weil die
beiden das ja auch angesprochen hatten
also die 13.000 sind sicherlich nicht
das Potenzial sondern wenn man sich
anschaut die unterzeichnet ist
manifestes sind schon deutlich mehr
200000 oder wie viel sind inzwischen
700.000 also
700.000 Leute die einen einen Manifest
unterschreiben was wir Patient sagt
intellektuell dürftig ist was aber
dieser dieser diffusen Sehnsucht nach
diesen Ausdruck verleiht und vor allem
dieser diesem Gefühl diese Sehnsucht
kommt in der politischen Debatte nicht
vor man wird wenn man Skepsis ist bei
Waffenlieferungen sofort als Putin
versteher diskreditiert diese ganze
Gemengelage die glaube ich Gebiet schon
ein Potenzial weil das genau wieder
darauf ein zielt einzahlt was was eben
schon mal funktioniert hat was bei der
AFD funktioniert hat wir werden gar
nicht wahrgenommen mit unseren Sorgen
und das ist doch nicht dumm dass man
irgendwie auch mit mit Putin reden muss
und so weiter obwohl mit Putin geredet
wird obwohl Verhandlungsangebote im Raum
sind aber das kennen wir doch aus
anderen Themen das Gefühl ich komme
nicht vor und deswegen glaube ich das so
eine Partei wenn Sie den richtigen
Moment erwischt und
Potential hätte und gefährlich sein
könnte für sogar für die AFD ähm
ja wenn die Populisten sich noch weiter
zersplittern du kannst ja nur gut sein
interessant ist ja diese Wortwahl das
kennt man auch aus dem Thema
flüchtlingskrise und vor allem aus dem
Corona Thema man darf bestimmte Dinge in
der Öffentlichkeit gar nicht mehr sagen
also das ist ja auch dieses Argument ich
bin für Frieden Diplomatie und
gegenwaffenlieferung und glaube dass
Waffenlieferung den Krieg eskalieren
aber das darf man alles nicht mehr sagen
genau also das heißt es ist genau das
gleiche die gleiche Wortwahl das gleiche
narrativ eigentlich dass wir schon immer
also in mehreren anderen hoch
umstrittenen politischen Themen kennen
aus den letzten Jahren das ist der große
Erfolg nicht nur der AFD sondern
eigentlich der gesamten neuen Rechten
und bestimmte erzkonservativer Menschen
die behaupten dass wir hier in
Deutschland kurz vor oder schon in der
Meinung Diktatur leben die von wokismus
reden die von angeblichen sprachverboten
reden
die behaupten dass die Medien irgendwas
steuern das ist ein Mainstream gibt das
Wort haben sie eben auch benutzt finde
ich schwierig
ich möchte auch wirklich nicht die AFD
ist auch keiner reine populistische
Partei mehr populistisch ist ein Markus
Söder der behauptet hier in Bayern bei
uns kann man noch freie Sprechen und
Wurst essen ja das kann man überall in
Deutschland vielen Dank die AFD ist eine
extrem rechte bis rechtsextreme Partei
je nachdem welchen Flügel man sich
anguckt und sie ist Demokratie feindlich
und das ist mehr als Populismus und
natürlich ist es ein Problem wenn man
dieses narrativ immer weiter verbreiten
kann also natürlich gibt's die
Meinungsfreiheit man kann sagen was man
will deswegen kann man auch das erzählen
aber das Problem ist halt wenn dann ich
sage jetzt mal mittigere Kräfte aus CDU
und Co auf denselben Schwan reinfallen
und den weiter verbreiten weil wir reden
seit einem Jahr darüber wie kann man
diesen Krieg stoppen wir reden seit zwei
Wochen ständig über dieses Manifest und
diese Demo also wo ist der
meinungskorrektur eingegrenzt lass mich
einfach einen kleinen Zwischenruf machen
eine verschiedene Spitzenkandidatin in
Berlin wäre fast eine solche nicht
geworden weil sie bekannte den
mädchenwunsch gehabt zu haben
Indianerhäuptling zu werden und das geht
gleich gar nicht ein
cdu-bundesvorsitzender ist neulich
furchtbar geflattet worden weil er doch
tatsächlich von keinem Pascha sprach
natürlich darf man sagen Indianer oder
Pascha man muss bloß derzeit in
Deutschland damit rechnen dass die
sozialen begleitkosten relativ groß sind
und das ist der das was gemeint ist mit
der Rede von dem veränderten
meinungskorrektur das Dinge die früher
einfach durchgegangen wären inzwischen
sehr stark finalisiert sind wobei
manches gut ist das ein Wort zu
gebrauchen gehört sich wirklich nicht
und manches ist dann leicht übertrieben
das ist das Gemeinte und die Aussage in
Deutschland nicht so etwas wie sozusagen
eine Normalität des Redens die man auf
Null Hochdeutsch auf englisch
also nochmal was ein Korridor gemeint
als Normalität des Diskurses und des
Gebrauchs von Worten ist doch gewiss da
wir wissen was normal ist und was nicht
normal ist und was etwas ist womit man
aneckt und nichts anderes ist die Rede
von Mainstream weil die selben Menschen
die immer sagen auch der Franz-Josef
Strauß der war so toll die die sozusagen
diese Art von politischen Streit
irgendwie gut finden die den heute noch
machen wundern sich dass es dann
Gegenwehr gibt was für eine weinerliche
Position ist das eigentlich
Gegenwehr und zwar ganz heftig aber ist
nicht
genommen und hat noch mal zurückgehalten
das sozusagen derjenige gegen den
gegenwärt sich nun erhebt moralisch
diskreditiert wird er wird mich
sozusagen als streitgegner mit dem man
sich raucht ernst genommen und selbst
die Gegner von Strauß Namen und Strauß
als Menschen und das intellektuellen
Ernst es ist sozusagen die moralische
Diskriminierung
wahrgenommen hat
nein also da würde ich auch wirklich
ganz vehement mal widersprechen wollen
also ich glaube nicht dass wir irgendwo
jemanden treffen der jetzt Friedrich
Merz das die diskursfähigkeit oder den
Intellekt abspricht wenn man solche
Begriffe nutzt sondern gerade also genau
und der absichtlich wie sollte man nicht
besser Meinungsfreiheit und auch
diskursfreiheit definieren können als
dass der Vorsitzende der größten
Oppositionsparteien im Deutschen
Bundestag in einer überaus prominenten
Talkshow sitzt und solche Begriffe
benutzen bewusst benutzen und damit auch
in die Debatte einbringen kann und ich
würde gerne also ich finde das
hochinteressant diese Debatte würde aber
gerne noch mal einen Punkt zu dem was
wir eben besprochen haben ergänzen
nämlich wenn man jetzt über eine neue
Gründung einer Partei womöglich sprechen
würde von Frau Wagenknecht dann besteht
ja eine Partei nicht daraus dass sie
sich auf einem einzigen Politik fällt
nämlich Friedenspolitik engagiert
sondern sie muss auch in anderen
Bereichen Angebote machen und da würde
ich sagen aus Sicht der AFD liegt
eigentlich das wahre Risiko wenn man
nämlich auch migrationskritischen
kooperationsfeindliche Positionen
vertritt beispielsweise alles Sachen die
Wagenknecht auch gegen die Parteilinie
der Linken in den letzten Jahren
versucht hat dann ist da das
Risikopotenzial aus Sicht der AFD und
gleichzeitig würde ich doch mal ein
großes Fragezeichen daran machen wenn
wir uns mal anschauen wie beliebt ist
der neue Bundesverteidigungsminister wie
viel Zustimmung gibt es immer noch zu
den Waffenlieferungen wie viel
abnehmende Sorge gibt es inzwischen
Daten von aus den letzten Tagen vor
einem atomaren eskalieren dieses Krieges
dann würde ich doch ein Fragezeichen da
machen ob das die große Bewegung ist die
sich da versammeln würde das ist ein
Teil es gibt ein Potenzial da bin ich
völlig bei ihnen aber ich glaube nicht
dass wir darüber sprechen dass das jetzt
die die die große Mehrheit wird und Herr
Keller Einsatz würde ich noch kurz
anschließen wollen weil wir über den
Mainstream Begriff gesprochen haben da
kann die Politikwissenschaftlerin mal
was beisteuern denn wir sprechen auch
von Mainstreaming und zwar genau in dem
Fall den Frau Müller eben beschrieben
hat nämlich wenn im Grunde in der
politischen Mitte stehen eine Kräfte
Position von rechts und rechts außen in
den Diskurs hinein holen und genau das
passiert sprachlich eben gerade dass wir
Begriffe einer rechtsextremen Partei
salonfähig machen indem wir uns dieser
Sprache an dienen und da hat die
Wahlforschung eine klare Antwort nämlich
dass die zeigt es hilft nichts das ist
eigentlich das was Markus Söder auch
gelernt hat nämlich es hilft nicht sich
dieser Sprache und diesen Positionen
anzugehen es schlägt sich nicht in
Wählerstimmen nieder sondern im
Gegenteil die CDU zum Beispiel war immer
gerade dann erfolgreich wenn sie sich
klar nach rechts abgegrenzt hat und das
ist eine große Frage meines Erachtens
fürs nächste Jahr wenn wir auf die
anstehenden Landtagswahlen in
Ostdeutschland
noch mal ansprechen die Frage ist ja
jetzt immer noch
wenn Sarah Wagen nicht diese Gründung
war machen würde würde das ein ein
Anlass für die früher links wählenden
jetzt AFD weltweiten Ostdeutschland
sozusagen
einfach gedacht
na ja
wir sind hier in dieser Mainstream
Diskussion das Problem ist doch das zwei
Drittel der Bevölkerung habe ich gesagt
habe dass sie sie Friedensverhandlungen
wünschen oder sagen wir als
intellektuelle Elite wieso
man Friedensverhandlungen machen der
will ja nicht in einer
die wollen alle Frieden aber die sagen
zu den größten Teilen von diesen zwei
Dritteln dass die Ukraine dafür nichts
aufgeben soll sondern ihre Gebiete
behalten sollen das gibt's halt gerade
nicht das ist nicht stimmt dass die
intellektuelle Elite sagt das geht
einfach nicht im Gegenteil wir hören ja
fast gebetsmühlenartig auch dass sich
gerade die politisch agierenden wünschen
würden man könnte Friedensverhandlungen
führen aber dazu gehört dann eben auch
eine andere Seite ich bin da ganz bei
Ihnen nur leider oder gibt es eben
dieses gefühlte Diskurs diese Blüte des
kursverlängerung und das ist das ist ein
Versagen der politischen Mitte dass sie
nicht Bereiter diskutiert das haben wir
in der migrationskrise bei Angela Merkel
erlebt und das Leben wäre Olaf Scholz
der nicht in der Lage ist obwohl er ja
eigentlich diese Zögerlichkeit hat das
so diskussiv rüberzubringen das ist in
die Mitte integriert und diese
Diskussion von der Mitte ausgeführt
werden ich sehe denke mal an die Natur
doppelbeschluss ja an dem Tag kann man
zwei eine sehr schön sehen zum einen
wurde aus der Mitte heraus diskutiert
nämlich es hat aus auf dem Bonner
Hofgarten war die Demonstration gegen
helmut kohlundus hat die Gesellschaft
von der Mitte aus ist da diskutiert bei
mitten durch die SPD gegen das Helmut
Kohl Helmut Schmidt ist daran gestürzt
es hat nicht die Ränder gestürzt
gestürzt obwohl man sagen muss dass
damals die Friedensbewegung irgendwie
genauso naiv war wie heute denn der
doppelbeschluss besagte nicht ss20 und
Pershing als Doppel wie man sie meinen
sondern doppelbeschluss bedeutet
Aufrüstung und Verhandlung und das
gleiche muss jetzt wieder passieren ein
doppelbeschluss Aufrüstung der Ukraine
aber natürlich immer Offenheit für jede
Möglichkeit für Frieden und dieser
doppelbeschluss wird von der Mitte Haus
offenbar nicht genug kommuniziert er
lässt auf offenbar Bevölkerungsschichten
draußen vor und das ist bedauerlich und
das ist eine Aufgabe für die
Volksparteien auch für die regierenden
Parteien diese de von der Mitte
auszuführen wenn sie wenn sie sich das
anschauen wie wie Sarah Wagenknecht
diese frustrierten einsammelt ist das
natürlich beängstigend ist dass diese
neue Partei wenn Sie das geschickt macht
natürlich das dieses Potenzial hätte
hätte die Zahlen gern aufklären weil wir
haben diese Umfrage nämlich auch gemacht
und letzte Woche bei uns beschrieben im
Spiegel ähm es ist so ja zwei Drittel
oder wahrscheinlich noch mehr der
deutschen wünschen sich Frieden
natürlich wer wünscht sich die nicht
aber nur 17 oder 22 %. also mich jetzt
nicht fest sagen sozusagen auf Kosten
der Ukraine dass die eben abgeben müssen
die Gebiete die jetzt Russland besetzt
hat 17 % sind noch nicht mal also sind
mehr als die 700.000 jetzt bei Frauen
waren vielleicht unterschrieben haben
das heißt
also klar aber gibt's ja auch noch ein
paar die da nicht wählen und ein paar
andere Parteien wählen und so weiter
aber
die Äußerung des früheren russischen
Präsidenten dann mit WF zu Gemüte führen
der ja gesagt hat diese sogenannte
Sonderaktionen Spezial Operationen die
muss uns soweit wegführen von der
russischen Grenze dass sie notfalls an
der Westgrenze der Ukraine oder an der
Grenze zu Polen stattfindet das heißt da
ist er völlig klar für jeden das
Russland überhaupt kein Interesse an
Friedensverhandlungen da muss ich glaube
ich jetzt nicht unbedingt überlegen wen
führt jetzt aus der Mitte raus diese
Position ich muss das ja nur zitieren
das ist ja die Wahrheit Haltung ich
würde gerne noch mal zu dem Thema AFD
und Linke in Ostdeutschland kommen diese
Frage wird fahrerwagen möchten
möglicherweise da noch anders aktiv
werden björn höcke hat er ja schon
vorgebohrt der hat Sarah Wagenknecht
Angeboten in die AFD einzutreten
völlig unabhängig davon ob das
realistisch ist wahrscheinlich nicht
sehr was hat die AFD Basis eigentlich zu
diesen Annäherungsversuchen an die linke
oder an die an die anderen
auch nicht Fraktion innerhalb der Linken
also es gibt einige Wagen nicht Fans bei
der AFD in Sachsen-Anhalt wurde vor
anderthalb Jahren oder zwei Jahren mit
einem Plakat mit Frau Wagenknecht drauf
sogar für die AFD geworden es gibt da
auch immer wieder Zustimmung wenn man in
den sozialen Netzwerken guckt auf
afd-seiten und so weiter man merkt jetzt
die letzten Wochen kippt so ein bisschen
was im Sinne von wir dürfen sie auch
nicht zu sehr jetzt hervorheben weil das
könnte uns ein bisschen Schaden bzw
müssen eigentlich den Leuten sagen wenn
ihr das wollt was SARAH Wagen nicht sagt
müsst ihr uns wählen weil wir sind die
die ihre Position wirklich komplett im
Programm haben ihre Linkspartei hat das
damit und so weiter hat die AFD jetzt
schon auch zumindest in Teilen Punkt und
deswegen ist es schon interessant ich
kann mir jetzt aktuell nicht vorstellen
dass die AFD ist inzwischen so
verwurzelt so empört so voller negative
Energie ihre Mitglieder und Anhänger
dass sie nur noch sich selbst besiegen
kann die CDU hat alles falsch gemacht
schon falsch machen konnte wenn man sich
das Ziel gesetzt hätte die AFD klein zu
halten inzwischen legt er die CDU sogar
die abgrenzungslinie in die eigene
Partei hinein auf diese Weise wird die
CDU nicht wachsen sondern weiter
schrumpfen und genau das werden die
Landtagswahlen des nächsten Jahres
zeigen
nach den Landtagswahl in Thüringen oder
wie gesagt ich würde ganz kurz wir haben
nur noch zwei Minuten früher löschen
macht noch mal ganz kurz wir haben nur
noch 2 Minuten wach noch mal ganz kurz
auf diese
Demonstration eingehen da wurde auch
signalisiert von den Veranstaltern also
Rechte wollen wir nicht haben aber wir
jeder der mit uns zufrieden darf kommen
soll aber seine Fahnen zu Hause lassen
verkürzt auf diese Kommunikation
entwickelt sich da etwas Neues und
möglicherweise eine neue Bewegung wenn
man sich auf auf der langen Zeit Schiene
aneinander annähert dass die Parteien
landschaftsverfahren das neue Bewegung
das zum Teil unsere bisherigen
Wahrnehmungen von Parteien relativiert
naja also das was Sie beschrieben haben
diese dieses Eingangsstatement der
Demonstration zeigt ja eigentlich ganz
offen über was man da redet nämlich im
Grunde sind deshalb gare und und
vereinfachende Ideen von wir wollen
nicht mit euch aber man distanziert sich
ja auch nicht man hat ja niemanden
gebeten zu gehen oder dergleichen also
es gibt da glaube ich annähungen aber
ich glaube wir sehen generell was frau
Müller hat's angedeutet auch durch die
corona-demonstration Querdenken
Reichsbürger und viele andere es gibt
eine diffuse Gemengelage da von Menschen
die sich unter einem Oberbegriff
irgendwie zusammenfinden können und das
darf natürlich der Politik den
politischen Handeln den nicht egal sein
ich würde aber auch den Eindruck
formulieren das ist es auch nicht wir
sehen Reaktionen von
Energiepreis Sicherheiten von
Hilfspaketen von anderem um sorgen
bestmöglich zu begegnen dass das
politisch kommunikativ manchmal besser
laufen könnte würde ich auch
unterschreiben aber wir sehen eben die
diffuse Lage ich würde sagen das ändert
sich gerade nicht unbedingt sondern wir
sehen eher dass das Milieu das während
der corona-pur und den Pandemie aktiv
war auch wieder aufflammen
ich bedanke mich bei Julia Reuschenbach
bei einem Katrin Müller bei Volker
Racing und bei seiner Patzelt Liebe
ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer morgen in
der Phönix Runde wer boxpläne was heißt
feministische Außenpolitik
aktuell ist bei Phoenix der Tag mit Anja
Chalet unter anderem die
Auftaktveranstaltung zu einem ganz
besonderen Jubiläumsjahr das hat
irgendwie heute auch in der Diskussion
durch die schemat 175 Jahre Demokratie
in Deutschland bleiben Sie bei uns
[Musik]
[Gelächter]